what's with the jeans hate you you can
use like the worst thing I've ever done
to anybody
yeah but it actually it makes things
clear yeah what I'm gonna fuck your mom
what your mom on we're gonna have sex
it's funny no it was fun
you're disgusting oh you said that it's
good to be back could be back in your
mom's house hi mommy
how have you been man I've been good
dude I I haven't been here in a while
because I got AIDS I got really sick uh
oh yeah that you haven't been back since
then right now man I got so fucking sick
not only did you get sick you got
everybody I got started really sick you
started a tidal wave of sickness and it
was actually the worst like I've like
you know you get colds and you get sinus
infections or whatever I get I think I
get more than most people even more than
most comics because you know we travel a
lot and everything yeah but I that was
like the worst one that lasted three
weeks three full weeks and you were like
in bed for a long period of time dude
right this is how bad it got I I showed
up I did I did I got sick in San
Francisco or actually right before I did
all those shows up there I got Sam and
Joe sick and then I came back and I knew
I was gonna travel in a few days and I
should have just definitely I mean you
have to listen to your body telling you
stuff but I always go no it's fine I can
I'm just pushed through this did was it
hard to go on stage that's sick because
I mean there was a point where Joe said
you know like you should just go home oh
he told me multiple times but he did it
like if he had said go home I guess I'd
been like all right but he was like hey
it's okay if you want to take you want
to take this off and I always I'm like I
have that mentality of like if
somebody's saying it's okay if you don't
want to do this I'm like nah shit that's
they're testing me yeah or just being
like I mean if you want to be a bit
about it so I was like oh no I'll push
through it I mean it seems like you had
good sets though yeah the sets went well
but I was dying as I did them and then I
mean it to the point where I couldn't
hear couldn't breathe out of my nose at
one point I almost couldn't speak
anymore
and then I came home I saw a doctor
right away he was like you are fucked I
didn't say that he was like he was like
you know you're really sick like you you
should just rest I got on a plane
two days later did a full weekend in
Newport at the funny bone well came back
home two days later got on a plane went
to Hartford and basically I got back
from Hartford and I was probably up to
like you know 85 90 % better and then it
was just you know but it was a full
three weeks I'd never I'd never been
that it basically felt like I was
getting I was you know about the he
thought I was on the line of getting
like some type of bronchial infection or
the flu or something you know right like
it was just I need to take better care
of myself I've started taking vitamins
and drinking water it's fun it's fun
because I got a very mild strain of what
you had like it yeah cuz I from Joe no I
said Sam probably because Sam came over
right after you guys went on and he was
kind of sniffling and then after he was
like yeah I'm sick I'm like what and my
my girlfriend got bad she didn't yeah
she was like not as bad as you I guess
but she was in bed for like three days
four days and then she's still had it
for like two weeks or something and then
I got like a mild version of it where I
was fine but I still felt like I had
something like I was really tired yeah
and I was bad yeah it was the first time
I've ever canceled Radio 2 and I've
always been like scared to do it like
you never want to do radio cuz I was
awful but right but like and I always
been like do I even have the juice to
tell them I don't want to go and I just
told him I go I'm not going to radio
tomorrow and the guy was like alright
and I was like yeah dude I need to sleep
like I can't I arrived I did the show I
was like there's no way I can get up at
6 tomorrow and go do awful radio and he
was like ok and I just slept 14 hours so
I was like I definitely know that the
sleep was a hundred percent what I
needed you know I mean yeah you know I
don't even think that's even a big deal
anymore I think radio nowadays isn't as
huge of a deal
I think it's absolutely a waste of time
I think widows really more powerful I do
I think that too I think the only time
this is how radio is effective now okay
if you're famous and you go to a city
and you do radio it's an advertisement
to let people know that a famous person
is there right but the whole concept of
like be really funny now in this segment
and it's gonna move a bunch of tickets
I think that's long gone and how many
people really tune in the terrestrial
radio I mean every car that I get in I
mean people from all ages have their
Bluetooth iPod go or plugged in yeah and
listen to what they want to listen to or
a podcast or something like that but
very few people are like no no it's
fucking it's you know it's it's it's
woody and the beaver we got we got it
you can't miss this segment like nobody
fucking says that ever yes in slacks or
the since why so you've been here the
BBC had a report and they were talking
about that they were talking about like
how you know nowadays you have your
iPhones you can hook up and there's just
like things like stitcher where you can
stream live podcast
yeah and they while they're showing how
to do all this they were showing death
squad while they're doing it like the
logo I saw yes look thank you yeah it's
so weird
that's so great wait so what did it what
did it say they were just explaining
like how nowadays you can hook up your
iPhone and shit to your your car stereo
using Bluetooth and different kind of
connections and stuff and they were
showing like how easy it was and what
what's available while they're doing
this they're showing this they're
showing like the death squad logo I am
playing and it was so weird it's like I
have all the podcasts how many podcasts
do you have under this umbrella no don't
no no because there's a few of them that
I do only on special occasions and then
there's ones like you know little
Esther's where I kind of put on the back
burner you know well she gets her shit
together a little and which of how many
regulars regulars mine you're sorry and
naughty show is prior to three regulars
really once and then I do kind of one
that you know where it's just me and I
guess once in a while I saw re up in
Vancouver - oh yeah yeah that's weird
who's this he was there the same weekend
right yeah he was there for the Just for
Laughs dirty show I guess it actually
towards I thought it was just part of
the Montreal right but they had a
theater a couple theater shows him
Jeff Ross and Jay oakerson big Jay
oakerson and Thea Vidale so they were
all doing a big theater there Wow
a couple shows and I saw them at the
fights - Wow
the fights were amazing it was so much
fun to go to the fights
I don't even you know they're the last
couple UFC's I'm starting to think they
stretch it
they're diluting their name a little bit
too much lately because it seems like I
don't know like the last month there's
been what three UFC s and there's one
next weekend yeah and so it's kind of
like I like I don't like the last couple
ones I just didn't care but I'm sure if
you're there is it a little bit
different but later yeah there's I mean
it's like a lot of sports but I think
fights are actually even more and like
I've been to football games i watch a
lot of football and there's something
about you know there's being out of
games exciting but you can watch you can
watch games definitely better at home I
think it's a bit but you cannot compare
being at a fight to watching a fight
being at the fight is a thousand times
better than just watching it watching a
fight it's fun but being there the
energy because it's a fight like I can't
you can't describe it's like when you're
you know at a bar and you see I get the
energy of being around a fight the
adrenaline is just it's incredible man I
heard that the the comedy shows there
was like lines down the block wrapped
around there was insane it's so crazy I
mean Joe is such an incredible draw like
in his his fans are so hardcore and
intense yeah yeah man like it's I heard
the weed was hate or I mean I mean that
not the cigarettes with that out there
no no it was it was he wants to be a
part of this conversation it was it was
intense yeah that was intense but this
shows the show the show we also did we
also popped in at a club there but the
the theater was fucking crazy you know
the capacity of the place like 11
something
they had 12 something Wow and the
theater the person that ran it said this
is the most people we've ever had at
this venue for any show ever Wow for
that theater that's amazing
hell yeah yeah when he said when he said
like I'm gonna sign pic I'm gonna sign
autographs and take pictures oh my holy
Christ that's when you just kind of
don't do that that's what being already
dipped out and went up front yeah yeah
yeah that's like torture man that's too
many people
yes that's like where you just like like
everyone let everyone go for like 30 to
40 minutes like go home and then you
come out and if there's a couple people
waiting then you're like but it was so
much fun and I always have a blast in
Vancouver mm-hmm and I really that's
like my one of my favorite places to go
for shows it's for a it's a beautiful
city man for shadow it's it's a great
time so I love you Vancouver I send you
my love thank you for being awesome
let's um let's bring a board a very
special guest people don't even know
who's here right now this is a gentleman
that I worked with we first met doing a
show a live show he might not even
remember but then we worked on a pilot
together and we just we really had a lot
of fun we we became buddies we've done
shows together he's extremely talented
extremely funny beautiful legs was nice
legs and you've seen him all over
television he's currently on TNT show
called Franklin and bash cool and he
plays a character named Pindar's all
right Pinder and it's Kumail Nanjiani
everybody if I'd known you'd be able to
see my hideous legs you have nice legs I
don't have those very hairy hello hello
mommy you have to say hi mommy
mommy I hope my mom he's not watching I
hope she's not either this is not
appropriate it's not appropriate for
real mothers you you really by the way
you look really fit thank you
you know member do you remember I saw Al
and I work out at the same gym this was
so great this was so great and I walked
in and he was he was like hit a tank top
on and so of course did you see your
friend and a tank top you're gonna be
like hey man nice nice guns right so I
saw him and I was like hey those arms
are looking great and his trainer I was
like 10 feet away and his trainer did
not pick up on that it was like done
kind of being a dick yeah yeah so he so
the trainer was like see see I told you
you look great he goes tell him again I
go you look he was so excited oh my god
yeah so he was like I told you I mean
that I've been affected yeah that guy he
was he's huge he is and he was so
earnest the way he was like yeah yeah he
was so sincere man thank you for coming
thank you yeah this this is very
exciting for me to have you here there's
so much I want to cover first of all
graduations on the show that you have
bigger on the oh thank you right now you
guys are in your second week airing
third week well it'll be the third one
this one's there will be the third
episode that's uh that's a fun show to
be yeah you guys have a great cast I
yeah yeah yeah I love doing the show
I've gotten so much shit for that show
why just cuz it will deal with promoting
it a lot during NBA and I think for a
little bit on Twitter to became the show
to like make fun of oh really yeah
just cuz because of the name and yeah
probably good though you know yeah yeah
how's it I mean it's doing well it's
doing well great yeah yeah yeah I mean I
don't know if it gets picked up or
whatever but I definitely like did a
couple of shows it's the shirt so it's a
like a lawyer right a law yeah mark-paul
Gosselaar bracken meyer they're like
ambulance chaser lawyers who don't
follow any of the rules yeah yeah they
don't have they don't know yeah but
there's they have they have a bet live
more of a conscience about what they do
right yeah yeah yeah they but they then
get absorbed by like a big corporate law
firm run right
Malcom McDowel Wow that is legendary
yeah when I where'd you meet him yeah oh
yeah you've done we were on the same
show how was that dude I when I did the
pilot when I got that I was like all I
want from this is I wanna text
Malcom McDowel once that's all I wanted
it yeah yeah that's all I wanted I
didn't care when to series if I sucked
on it so then there was one night where
I was like hey we're gonna go out give
me your number so I can text you we're
gonna go to a bar and then I texted
fucking McDowell
that's amazing he came out he came out
with us and he responds you've received
a text maybe from him as well yeah yeah
yeah people like I'm not fucking yeah
but he showed up yeah that's amazing
did you use a lot of happy faces yeah he
talks like a valley girl house he's
British right yeah he's super he's like
so down to her it's super nice boys for
everybody who might not know naka
McDowell of course was the star of
orange famous yeah like clockwork orange
is obviously like one of the best and
most epic films right like you can't
really yeah oh my god if you do like
it's like being in like Goodfellas and
you like what else you've been in like
who cares okay yeah I was in Goodfellas
they wanted to have a poster in our
office during the show a poster of talk
with orange but they were like that's a
mindfuck you can't have that yeah that's
rad that was really obsessed with that
movie for a while look at him I just
came out on blu-ray a new blu-ray
edition yeah yeah he was like promoting
that and stuff he was also in God of War
which I was playing at the time God of
War three Oh real nice playin it and I
got to like this level and I was like
that's welcoming down Kumail is like an
intense gamer where we wrote together on
a pilot and you know a lot of writers
offices have like video games like
things like that
to you know take breaks and distract and
like Kumail was the one who was like no
no no like this is gonna be part of the
routine
not just this isn't like something that
I might research yeah well it was Maddie
Koresh - Maddie was the most positive
guy in the world
anybody Maddie would be like like we had
we've run through scripts member like
ten times are you surprised you wrote
this part man yeah oh yeah it was like
it was and it's like all the execs and
then Maddie's laughing so hard but what
I mean I would be I I like being around
somebody oh yeah it's so great somebody
who's super positive
you know actually on I remember now
Franklin and bash is one of many
basically every audition that I've been
on
you did you did an audition for it I had
to switch one Franklin or bash one of
the two you did really I really did and
then it's like one of those things where
have you have you had were you audition
and then like you know you're like you
get the sides and you go in you reading
you're like dad that went all right or
that was terrible whatever and then when
the show comes out you're like and I was
never gonna like that was and then
you're just like and the only thing you
can be like oh I got in front of the
casting people yes but then you're like
that was such a bet so like I think that
like that's literally one of the times
one of the many times I'm sure we're
like I've walked in a room and like
someone's just like what the fuck what
are you doing here well you're like I'm
not delivering something I just want
turn this on I definitely but you know
what the original part of Breckin Meyer
was written to be sort of fat man I
didn't I mean I was it was like what did
I think it was written it's like a sort
of a no I mean like a schlubby dude oh
that's oh that makes me feel much better
yeah what if it was like a short fit guy
yeah yeah no that that's much better
oh yeah that's how it was written maybe
that's maybe that's how I got the part
or the sides at least yeah I did one I
did an audition for this movie coming
out called 30 minutes or less which
actually looks really funny with Aziz Oh
Aziz and Swardson and Danny McBride
right Yes sorts ins and there Danny
McBride is in it yeah yeah yeah and it
has really funny and I didn't get it and
then I saw that my part when did Danny
McBride and I was like oh why you
clearly wanted Danny McBride yeah yeah
that isn't that's by the way Matt curse
just said hello he's watching right now
Matt he curses the shit man yeah Matt
would be like the guy you want like on
every team oh yeah yeah and like you'd
be like a fumble he'd be like it was
beauty like this is a thing that's
probably been like over discussed but as
comics I feel like I have to at least
get everybody's take on it yeah that is
the Tracy Morgan thing from over the
weekend oh yeah if somebody if you don't
know about it amazing but Tracy Morgan
Tracy was doing zany's in Nashville and
he went on a rant that could you could
only I guess qualify as like intensely
homophobic in like anti like hate speech
essentially what was weird about it was
wasn't it it just wasn't that gays are
bad it was you should hit them well it
was a different level he said if my son
is my son were gay I would stab him yeah
instead if there's pipe on the
playground there are kids who might be
gay beat him till they're not gay oh
yeah I mean he said like they can take a
joke they take dick up that that's
that's a really bad joke here okay I
feel multiple ways about this there's
there's a I mean when you read
everything you're like it's terrible
it's not funny and I don't defend it at
all then part of me goes like well it
really sucks to have I imagine if
every night things that you do are like
you know examined or you know I when
you're on stage I just feel like we're
getting that we're getting more and more
and the more exposure you get the more
famous you become I imagine like every
show like you go on tour and every show
like people are like I mean it's not
this but like tonight you know Kumail
said this one joke and this is what it
was it was kind of lame and you're like
well that's kind of the thing like I was
thinking was like I mean I want to make
it like really clear I don't condone
what he said I didn't it's not funny at
all and it was it was actually like it's
a horrible thing when you think about
how far he went with it but like do you
feel like if you like you at some
sometimes when you don't have like a
well-written joke not even new sometimes
you just talk yeah if is there like are
there limits to what you think somebody
should be able to get into like I just
feel like the worst thing that I've ever
said on stage is horrible and and not
funny
right and the only reason no one knows
about it because I'm not famous and
there weren't enough people there that
cared yeah but now we're in like the
social media age where literally people
could like tweet from the audience you
know this is when I lived in New York
like a year ago he did a show at
Carnegie Hall where he said a lot of
homophobic stuff and people walked out
and it was news in New York for just a
little bit and then it got totally
covered up like fer people got on yeah
so this is not just a thing that he said
spur-of-the-moment he said some of those
lines they said well he said at Carnegie
Hall says this is a bit they just got
it's like yeah it's a written bit it's
intensely huh I mean he's an remember um
do you know Tim Hardaway the basketball
player yeah when he was on he was on I
think lava tards show in Miami Dan lava
tard show Miami and on the air he was
like look man like they're just
interviewed he's like I hate gay people
that's right you're like whoa
and you have to answer the apology yeah
he has to issue an apology rather but I
don't know like it's just I I don't
defend what he said at all but I just
feel like like how much more will people
like will this happen in other words
like well comics continue to like famous
comics really yeah you know say stuff
and then will it be hey man like you
couldn't be good I mean a lot of great
comics say awful awful things yeah I
first of all I think it should be a meme
like gay guys jacking off - that should
become like a - Tracy Morgan yeah send
it to him um I think actually I had I
did the show once in New York where like
John Mayer dropped in and he was really
drunk and he was kind of a real dick to
me ya think yes but then I sort of felt
bad for him because he just had a weird
bad night he had a bunt you get a bat
said he was drunk but then it was like
reported everywhere where there's a
video of you like leaving that Club or
something right so there is a video of
the actual performance but I made sure
that nobody like got it
and like there that show was taped Wow
yeah so it's somewhere he's fucking with
you during his set like he's trying to
well I should know he doesn't set I
don't want to get into it again I he
doesn't set I go on stage yeah and then
he runs up during my set uh-huh grabs
him the microphone and starts like being
like really shitty and mean to me yeah
and I get it was really weird it was a
weird whole thing but then that was
reported like in a lot of like local New
York things yeah I just feel like I
don't know I just feel like it is a
weird line for me like I I'm sure I'm
saying like good comics like Patrice
O'Neal I'm sure has said awful shit
awful awful shit finding his jokes you
know like he's a guy who says like
intensely polarizing things sometimes
yeah and you know or whatever Jim Norton
or somebody like that like they say like
you know shit that could be that you go
oh and they I watch that I go he's
looking he's trying to find his job yeah
but I mean
you're saying that like but you make a
good point which is that like this is a
recurring theme with the theme with this
guy any clearly harbors like real feel
like this isn't like I'm trying you know
whatever gays or what and he's just like
no seriously I mean this something
happened and I mean I don't know the
Kings we said it I could see that being
like a funny thing like if my son was
gay
yeah it could be right but I could see
it but it's you have to be so
responsible because that is a big
problem right now and like the gay
suicides in school do ya know yeah just
a few months it was a huge thing so I
think at at best
it's like horrifically responsible yeah
just say like you just have to be
careful and yes or no he's a public
figure
yeah stuff he does it is going to get
reported and he just has to you know I
mean that's a risk it's a responsibility
the other side of it which I find
questionable is it's clearly a terrible
thing and they've addressed you know NBC
issues in a state Tina Fey does is he
held to a different standard because we
kind of all go well he's fucking he's
weird and like yeah totally
because Alec Baldwin says that like I
had a thing it's not like we're gonna
talk to him he had a bad night and he
was sleepy yeah like it's gonna be like
we got a new guy on the show he's he's
fucking gone yeah yeah
yeah I mean I like Baldwin had that
thing with his daughter remember but I
find that to be that's like friend I
think that's extremely different yeah I
mean it was a unfortunate incident it
was like you can criticize him but it
was a there's a private voicemail where
he's you know there's a lot of real
things going on there a divorce an
intense battle for what's a cool that's
a personal it's a very personal thing
and like you know you said something
that like it's regrettable to what he
said and how he said it to his own shit
it's his own shit this is like gays
should be dead like yeah it's it's you
know I actually said something on
Twitter about how like because he's sort
of considered wacky and weird we give
them a little bit of pasta yes but then
a lot of people started like arguing
with me on it
well yeah and I deleted those tweets cuz
I just didn't want to like deal with it
anymore do you guys think that he's
almost playing a character on purpose to
try to get as many like do you think he
goes home and goes to his wife and goes
haha dude Isis I'm fuckin no I don't you
don't you you think he's at home he's
fuckin I'm pregnant get in my belly and
all that shit
III think he's kind of bananas and I
think that like you know like that
pregnant thing he's said it so many
times now it's like kind of and then I I
I know I think that he for him if you
know a lot of times he does shows really
fucked up and he'll do shows which like
comics would be like just know there's
not a lot of jokes going on there like
he'll just you know yeah wild it was in
Denver a month ago and he was doing the
other Club and South yeah yeah how great
was that Club I thought it's the best
it's the shit where Comedy Works
downtown it's incredible it was so much
yes well so am I get it
they're both good but haven't done the
other one but that's what Tracy was
playing and it felt like people were and
also Charlie Sheen was there that
weekend damn there's a lot of
competition yeah
but no I think he's out of his mind
anyway yeah I mean he doesn't dude he he
doesn't do really like I mean he can
this thing's not capable or fun he's a
funny dude but like yeah just kind of
huh he is a funny he's a funny dude he's
a really funny dude he's the kind of guy
to that I mean in a way he was like I
think he's kind of a writers dream if
you get what makes him funny because
Tracy can like say two words and it can
be hilarious or he can react like he's
the guy who can just look and you're
like and just you fall out laughing it's
all about just like understanding what
makes him funny he can do lines that
nobody else could absolutely absolutely
no he's he should be given credit for
being a funny dude but that's just it's
crazy shit what he said but I just do
feel like I mean on top of like will
this happen more I think it's gonna
happen more I think I think I mean like
the with the way Twitter and and like
yeah this was just the reasons no story
there between famous people and audience
the story broke because an audience
member
our Facebook yeah just posted a thing
and like that's now you know that's a
newt like there was no way to do that
five ten years ago no no you have to be
like writes up you have to write like a
letter you know the paper or something
yeah it looks like he's sucking on Sarah
Silverman's finger okay
she's smiling she's into it she's gonna
do it he's you know I've always had this
weird when specially when he was on
Saturday Night Live not too much
recently but I always thought he was
bisexual you know so it's kind of odd
for me nothing that he even is being
does this because I always thought he
had a little game well that might make
sense that yeah that could be I I mean I
don't know maybe he is he's I he he's a
while do I mean you mean when he got in
trouble in at the radio station in
Florida for right like that was a he got
charged with like sexual assault really
yeah he went into it like some girl was
on the air and he I think he went in and
like he took her shoes off start licking
her feet and then like that's what he
went for I think he groped her and stuff
if you're gonna get sexual harassment
yeah get a little more feet yeah get
some ask if some grab a tittie get it
grab a tittie attention today I don't
know if you caught what we played when
we introduced you
well we were playing proud to be an
American was it yeah I just lost my
citizenship test I feel like I've
arrived wasn't an easy test it was so
easy I went in and the dude was like
don't worry I haven't failed anyone in
years
don't worry what's good and then he told
me I don't know am I supposed to talk
sure again come on dude haha he so he
started talking to me and I feel like
most people that are there don't really
speak English that well most people who
get just because I was in line for it
and I asked a person in front I was like
what I was like it's just a line for the
sitting of test
he was like 1492 like he was they had
just memorized their answers they didn't
know all right
it really was so so I think he was sort
of happy to see somebody who he could
talk to oh wow cuz he talked to me for a
while well and he was telling me oh I
don't know is this this is okay to say
yeah
will this be out there forever no it'll
go away
yeah what it yeah seriously I don't know
well is there an archive of this Brian
yeah yeah yeah it's on iTunes right
well I this guy told me that he was oh
man I'll let me wait till I take my oath
and then I can do it okay now the
story's built up too much yeah I know
man it's really like you're really
people are gonna write in just change
the name why wouldn't you say anything
yeah he said that he was Jet Li's like
he was Jet Li's question person like I
went Jet Li was doing citizenship yes
and he didn't know Jet Li wise and he
was like this dude was smiling at me so
I was like this guy's hitting on me so
he went and complained to his supervisor
he was like hey he said this guy's okay
this is what the tester told me he's
like I said this guy's a gay he's
hitting on me and the guy was like no
that's Jet Li he's a super star and then
Jet Li complained to his lawyer being
like this guy didn't know who I was what
the fuck and he rejected his application
what because Jet Li hadn't been paying
his child support
Wow how's that you shouldn't be telling
me I should know no but the best is that
he's like smiling it yeah there's a gay
in there yeah and the dude even if Jet
Li's gay he is way out of this dude's
league like this dude was like short
bald in the 60s like he probably had
that smile right there yeah to the left
there in the gray
what he was looking at very he was like
test test here no but this brings me
home on I because I've been wanting to
have this conversation so badly with you
we started this conversation one time I
asked you these questions and I think
you really what the fuck is wrong with
you but that is okay for obviously
people would know you were born and
raised in Pakistan yeah
and came over when you were 19 yeah and
you never saw stand-up yeah I never
really seen until like you were came
over the states
yeah I'd seen one like mr. bean thing
but it wasn't stand-up it was when he
does like his weird sketches one person
things you know yeah but this is okay
this is what like blows my mind and I
think somebody could misinterpret this
but you okay a lot of foreigners that
come to the states have a kind of a
different grasp of what comedy is I
think do you know what I mean by this
like people come here and they they
don't have a they usually don't have a
you have a very sophisticated sense of
humor like you you grasp like all the
new like you perform them like you you
haven't like you get nuanced what makes
things funny did you have that
sensibility when you're 16 17 18 yeah
did you understand what was funny did
you find like to do I did the things
that make you that you kind of make you
laugh now that you find funny would that
make you laugh then I mean you know you
change as he grow up but I think I mean
you know I grew up watching a Hollywood
movies I didn't really watch that many
comedies I liked like horror and sci-fi
so I watched like you know ghostbusters
and stuff that was the comedy but yeah I
mean I thought stuff was funny and I
mean a personal life like things that
made you laugh at home or whatever would
it be I was a pretty serious you pretty
serious yeah I had a pretty funny family
yeah but I was a pretty serious kid oh
my god
see really like man I really like I
wouldn't go when I was a kid I wouldn't
go to stores and like I couldn't like
pay money to buy stuff like I was that
shy really to like I was pretty old yeah
no shit why did you get this I guess was
very insecure I was very very insecure
so like if there if you wanted something
you'd be like go with me or there you
know what it was I thought honestly this
is too heavy I thought I was like really
ugly as a kid like I thought it was
super ugly and I wouldn't go to stores
cuz I thought they wouldn't tell me
stuff cuz they thought it just gets too
ugly really mm-hmm
till I was like pretty like old like I
thought I was like really really too
ugly for people to really yeah it's like
so long now why did you think that other
people telling you that or did you
parents serve you said a complex about
it
yeah but really bad complex about it to
put it like you put it on yourself like
or like you heard people would tell you
know people wouldn't really tell me I
think what I think at some point
somebody said like I remember this is so
my mom used to make fun of me because I
had like a big nose yeah so I think
that's where I came from she didn't mean
anything by it she was just being funny
sure nothing on her but he didn't
realize how much it affected me so I
think so yeah since I was a little kid I
remember like for many many many years
until I think I came to college or
something I had a pretty awful complex
about oh my god okay
I would like what I ate and stuff I was
like very super careful about it for
like weight and everything yes since you
know when I was like 14 15 and stuff
like that I really had a serious complex
yeah yeah it was you must be amazed that
you have a beautiful wife I mean are you
like yeah she can't see the real me when
I was five
Jesus she would divorce me yeah it's
pretty heavy
that is heavy yeah I haven't ever really
talked to anybody about this well I told
her I think you're a beautiful man I
think you're beautiful no no but no but
that's all beside the point like now I
don't really care about
looks as much I think you sort of lose
it as you get older you're like right no
really doesn't really matter how but
it's so funny the extreme like when you
think about the extreme of being so shy
feeling so bad about like I can't go to
the store to pay stuff to you in front
of audiences and yeah I do think is
crazy it can come from the same place
though like there's like a lot of I
think there's a lot of comics who are
pretty like introverted and shy and for
sure for sure jump on actually I think
only the good ones but I don't think
there's any of it I really don't think
that like usually like somebody who has
like a part of them that's like has that
serious sincere introverted thing yeah I
find they're not on yeah they're much
funnier than the guy who's bouncing off
the wall yeah you definitely see people
who are like very quiet and shine and
get onstage and they light up and
they're amazing yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah and then they get off its back to
it it's back to yeah because I think
they get what they want from the stage
they're not looking for validation 100%
of the time yeah that's so but like yeah
that's the thing that like I guess I
know I just found it so interesting I
mean you you didn't see even standing up
and then the first I saw was the Jerry
Seinfeld I'm telling you for the last
time which was his last HBO our that was
the first and if I saw which was like 99
right what did you think of that when
you saw it was the best thing I'd ever
seen
really I was like you can do this this
can be a job like crazy
this can be out here in college when you
see the house in college I hadn't
watched the show very much I've caught
up since then and I love the show but
I've never really watched a show that
much and I watched that special in like
blew my mind yeah I think it's so
amazing is so I mean I think it affects
me more because I have like basically a
foreign half of my family I like my mom
from Peru and I grew up with just so
meant so much of like a foreign you know
influence in the house like cousins
aunts uncles friends of hers you know
and there's just all this thing and
humour always seemed like it was like
some of them are extremely funny and
everything is like you know I haven't
got languages of thing to mean you
obviously speak fluent English so that
kind of
adds to it but what I do sing it what
helped me kind of was coming from a
different place and you sort of noticed
things more because it's different and
you realize that things don't have to be
a certain way or whatever and then even
language stuff because you're picking up
Kate you're picking up the what's the
word for it I'm so fucking for addiction
or cadences yeah the just the way people
talk like the lexicon yeah yeah like the
casual way people talk you know like
saying things like cool like yeah I
never said cool till I was 18 you know
so you sort of sort of pick up these
things so late that you can actually
process them and think about them yeah I
guess the other thing is that you know a
manager speaks to you your ability as a
comic obviously but like all those
things you know you think about like oh
yeah somebody comes over and they see
things differently and everything like
that but for usually usually
foreigners that when they come over
is that like derogatory the way I'm
saying that I don't mean it to man I
think it's the the sneer when you say
okay then you're flicking him off I'm
sorry in Tim you need people from like
shitty places like they will be it's
almost like they also all jump on the
same thing like they'll point out the
same thing like you've seen like comics
from another country and then they hit
the stage and you go like you know yeah
they're all gonna they're gonna hit all
the all the marks you never do like did
you stand up start like that no never
well I started after 9/11 so I was like
who's right after 9/11 there were a kind
of like Muslim American Arab could like
there were a fucking ton of them who
were like using it to get like famous
yeah and a lot of them were gone now I
knew so many of these guys and they were
all doing the same jokes killing doing
the same joke you never did know because
I like you know the people I liked would
like Seinfeld I really left Woody
Allen's stand-up like stuff like that
that I'd seen which had been a ballsy
choice man I was like yeah it was it's a
ballsy choice I was freaking out I
didn't know what to do with my life I
was like good at nothing you could
student I was a good student yeah but I
didn't really care about anything like I
didn't want to do any like I was a
computer science and philosophy major
really yeah
Christina oh by the way um piece of shit
Christina the other mommy yeah she was a
philosophy major
oh why she was yeah so this would have
been a really fun for her but yeah my
like my house is all like philosophy
books about it'll always elect Tom I
didn't ya know I don't I don't know
garden each Nietzsche I don't know yeah
yeah yeah like everything here garden
yeah everything is in the house but
anyways the reason obviously she isn't
here if we haven't addressed that is
that she's in the Middle East yeah
shitting in plastic bags if she actually
shitting in fact because that she I
don't think that standard over there
it's not it's because he's punking
message thing she's she's uh she
bringing him back can she bring him back
I would so love it do she isn't a couple
of these faces are like a pretty remote
and they don't have like if the base is
a decent size they don't have plumbing
at all or porta-potties so you shit into
a plastic bag and then you throw it into
the locals houses the ability to like a
kid like a kid on a bike just like a
school USA absolutely it's a Nathan of
steel drum that uh has a fire going you
set your shit on fire if the fire is
just going the whole time and so you
just throw it in there and then it
evaporates you're not you know whatever
it burns up oh man what are you going I
just took a shit here let's be honest
you did a double stack you know that I
still I do the thing I think most people
that are like their minds and bodies
operate in a healthy way will go like
like you go oh like when you feel the
sensation you go I have to go the
bathroom
yeah I was sitting here yeah I had to
like intense thing and I got to start
right and I go I'll just I'll just sit
through all these go through the show
like this and then I'll shit later like
and it was clearly like no you got to go
like ya know and I was like no I'll just
put and then like a minute passed by and
I was like there's no way I could sit
through an entire show so much better
get that shit out of
I don't even like I hate I hate shitting
though I hate that we have to do it in
his gross I love it
I bugs me like I don't like to think
about it I know like everybody else who
has like shit inside them yeah when
you're making out with a hot girl she
has like shit insider yeah when she
farts and you smell it that's particles
from her butt that are in your nose um
no you and the wife worst talk shit like
give shit conversations I don't know I
don't fart around her really you're one
of those yeah I don't like to deal with
it at all you excuse yourself where you
just walk out of the room or yeah I
don't even yeah I do you make a show of
that you'd be like I left something at
the mailbox not at all no so you'll just
be like casual I go check the mail six
times a day just but UDL will like sneak
out of the room yeah and I think she
probably knows when you know and if she
did the same for you yeah wow we don't
we're not a we're not comforting couple
I'm not comfortable with my body yes so
far like a lot of friends are like you
and they're like no - and then Christina
and I mean everybody we're like oh like
we fart on each other like yeah
I just had a fart off where I put two
our assholes together we tried to fire
at the same time to see if we can like
it would be like a tug of war to see who
gets brighter we will never have a kind
of love know why not cuz I hate I hate
he really hates it I don't think I don't
think shit stuff is funny really yeah
yeah my dad had a really dirty sense of
humor like he had all these fucking legs
they're like oh yeah I feel like you're
hating your body no no no no oh but he
would talk about like farting shit a lot
he dead these jokes are never said I
wish you had my body so you could really
I never thought that like I I think it's
like super gross that I don't like to
think about it so your dad your dad like
shit in fart jokes oh yeah all the time
I would love your dad we need to have a
totally hang out yeah all did your dad
ever fart on you as a kid my dad was
fired yeah boogers did you do boogers he
would fight boogers over there yeah
wait so you can bugger is this one a
little bit of shit comes out right oh
yeah right oh no no I'm just
playing yes anyway slashing boogers down
that I actually I find boogers actually
nose but not shit boogers yeah I find
nose boogers to be repulsive okay I have
kind of er but I mean I have like that I
wouldn't say a phobia but I like if
somebody's like picks their nose and I
go holy shit and I the eyes water
yeah like when the whole thing remember
like growing up especially when you're a
kid and kids would eat their boogers
dude dude I like people still be like
you didn't do the effort I'm like fuck
no do it like it's intense I can feel it
inside how repulsive I have such an easy
once I remember I was in Chicago I got
on the bus and I sat down next to this
guy and I noticed like everybody's
sitting really far away from him yeah
and I look and this guy has like things
on his skin like he's got like scabs and
lesions and stuff like it's all red and
black and shit like all over and he's
picking the scabs and he's eating them I
don't think you people are looking at me
like I can't wait till he sees ya and I
see that looking F nobody's looking at
the dude everybody's looking at me oh
yeah I can feel it right now back I
remember in college there was a you know
there's like in every class there's a
real fucking weird like you know like
you're like this dude hey there's a kids
in there he was he was weird all the
fucking time but one day I'm sitting in
class and just some boring he was
microeconomics class I look over and
this kid is picking his face right and
then he's going and looking at it and
then he's eating it so he's picking open
something on his face but then he saw
you know even someone catches you being
like
he was just like you know he wanted to
get back to that meal yes delicious yeah
that was that was his his joy that's the
thing too is like you learn about I just
found out a friend of Mines like sibling
loves eating raw hamburger meat yeah and
I was like what yeah I didn't know that
was a thing but all that stuff goes by
accident tartare is that but they put
like spices yeah he likes raw ground
beef it's horrifying but you know that
that is like a childhood thing like at
some point yeah without knowing what he
was doing did that and that becomes kind
of long but I used to eat cold hot dogs
you know and then now I uncurse disgust
me yeah that was no I loved cold hot
dogs even when a specially when I had
the cheese in the middle of it and then
like you eat it raw it's so good but
nowadays I think of that and I just gag
fuck that I yeah I I don't want to think
of food as being animals ever so like I
even get mistakes like well done cuz you
really uh I don't like the blood coming
on well donek blood like yeah man that's
a waste of a steak like he knows like he
has something to eat chicken and it does
like in a vein yeah he's steak I saw a
man yeah well when chicken has a clot in
it and you Oh system have you ever
cracked an egg and there's like a blood
clot yeah that feels good you know
because you know as a baby yeah yeah
yeah I like the melon I ate a baby oh I
know how long how long we've been on I
know okay we got to get coming out of
here
I actually honestly want to keep talking
about how you develop an act as somebody
who came over I find it so fascinating
yeah I really do I mean I find it so
fascinating oh by the way if you don't
know like it's not like oka mail does
stand-up sometimes like he's done
Letterman Conan what Kimmel
yeah Fallon Fallon oh just just all
that's awesome man yeah like he's been
on everything and he taught you know he
tours all the time and they like you're
not like you know competent at it like
you're obviously prolific at it like you
really know how to do stand-up I just
find it so crazy that you can come over
here I mean obviously you have a gift
for it but be like 20 years old 19 years
old yeah it was desperation like I
honestly was like I don't know what the
fuck I'm gonna do with my life like ya
good at nothing that I want to do and
everything like if it was if it was a
way to make money out of video games
that's what I would have been doing you
know but like stand-up like when I got
to college and I got friends and I got
more confidence people would tell me
that I was funny yeah my friends were
like you should try stand-up yeah so
that's how I tried it and it like
honestly my first set was to this day it
was in front of friends and stuff
yeah one of the best that's ever had
really yeah being so cocky walking
offstage like remember thinking I could
do Letterman next week if I wanted
really yeah and I mean I look at this
jokes they were horrible I did like 20
minutes you did 20 minutes cuz I mean
you know you're in college it was all
friends like everybody was you know
having fun and yeah and it was awful I
mean it was atrocious but I was lucky in
that I didn't if I bombed but here you
see some people that like you're like
you've been doing it for three years
you've never had a good set it's just
impressive that you're still doing it
yeah oh yeah or when it gets to like six
and you're like still huh geez yeah and
then there's actually there's another
level that we're like you'll there are
some people who they were doing it
before I did it like they were like
already around I've been doing it now
yeah nine years so they're that plus
however long they were doing it and they
still have a I would just say like a
very low batting average yeah every time
you do okay what's gonna say when
Rasheed Wallace shoots threes you know
you're like you make every fifth one
right keeps shooting three launch them
I like when guys like Wallace who was it
this year somebody was it was it uh Glen
Davis or somebody somebody on the
Celtics they were down or something in
the in the playoff game and like they
just like you know they needed to like
move the ball and obviously and it
wasn't a three-point I think it was like
Glen Davis shot and then they like you
know call timeout after it like he
misses the shot and you see what's the
what's Doc Rivers the saddest coach they
cut to him like like we know that little
beat before you go to commercial yeah he
goes a three really a three clearly like
you don't fuckin man is the best he's
like really a three he's like you never
make him in practice Glen Davis did he
start crying again you ruined when the
kg made Glen Davis cry oh you've seen
that when he's on the bench like ripping
on him this was I think it was last
season when he's on the bench newzik
Roper got him and Glen Davis like
clearly starts crying vaguely remember I
remember a great crying thing was when
Nick Saban was coaching the Dolphins and
they were just starting mini camps like
before the season and one of the players
they drafted I think I forget where he
was from a defensive lineman maybe from
SC was they were doing like the
stretches before practice yeah and he's
just like mom like you can just see like
it's like from a distance but you can
see like fucking pointing and head
shaking yelling yeah these tears I mean
streaming out and you're like NFL
defensive lineman like bawling and the
thing was they found out that he came
into camp out of shape so he was
basically like you fat tinted piece of
shit like that's just ripping on him
well you know what your only job in life
is to be in shape that's it that's it
millions of dollars that's all you're
just yep I love when Spoelstra this
season was like guys did in the locker
room were crying about the heat yeah
remember that like yeah yeah like three
months ago I love that yeah yeah yeah
that's great man
I'm happy to see the mavs when I was
happy to see the heat loose which is how
everyone was and then I was watching him
loose and I felt kind of bad but then
they showed the clip of like the three
of those dudes at the beginning of the
season like dancing you know in this
fireworks I was like fuck I'm not
talking about five when I talk about six
not talking about seven not talking
about a decade running championships
yeah that was pretty great I mean the
whole thing I'm just not like I don't
like intensely hey any of those players
or anything but I am NOT a fan a big fan
of like assembling an all-star squad as
you're yeah like that was the whole gang
of waiting you know it's like really you
got nine all-star like yeah I think the
Globetrotter it really is like your your
payroll is like 300 fucking million
dollars for like it's it's just it's
insane and then there's teams that that
fucking throw in the towel other teams
that are just like no no like we don't
spend money and yeah what I think like I
don't know I still am a fan of like the
team has a great player and you get a
supporting yeah I like the bowl I like
that I like that more
okay we're gonna do this even though I
would love to keep this conversation I
want to get coming out of here I want
you to watch this video give me your
thoughts on it
and just tell me how many tell me how
many views do you think this video has
but also you can give me your thoughts
on all right all right I haven't seen it
yeah you've never seen this this is
technique tree
women are no 2 the real video this is a
guy just showing you how to do massage
which I just recently had the same
technique done to me how'd it feel it's
great for those that can't see it's a
back like hamstring and inner thigh
massage and see how far he goes up and
that's a yeah you can see her buttocks
flinched for this so it's not her when I
had what I had when I have a semi when I
had it done they went even a step
further yeah her hand well that's where
he's found yeah really yeah hand touch
your bone yeah and then she climbed on
top of me and she was just like
massaging me her whole time her boobs
are like rubbing against me she Asian
you know I couldn't talk because it was
like pitch dark cousin real in your face
is down like you you have to take off
your clothes and this being her boxers
with your face down and like that little
hole yeah and then she turns off like
all the lights what city was this over
you in Burbank oh do you remember Boyd
telling us that story about his friend
would go and get blowjobs
yes that was a madness that was this
inch on the table and there's a hole and
you would get a blowjob from a motel how
many views do you think it has shit I
should have not met views but just use
like ten thousand mice if I originally
saw that video I would have said like
two hundred forty something like that
you can you pull it up yes it's like
you'll reveal it yeah 218 million three
hundred seventy six it's a top ten
YouTube video involved on 218 million
views what you know what I almost think
that is I almost it's like a joke yeah
like I almost like somebody that works
at YouTube so I can't just gonna go in
the database and add a couple of numbers
and stuff you know what I mean yeah it's
a top 10 or top 20 yeah all the time
yes in the second one Chaz the second
one has eleven thousand million eleven
million really yeah five years a lot I
have leg massages
I just want to add the comment it's like
people making fun of it yeah a lot he
had a disable he disabled an inner thigh
one there was there's an inner thigh
massage video because I was clicking
through and it was like cuz you knew
that it was just like pull that cock it
was all like who's gonna come now and
then it was just like now I'm taking
this shit down
yeah man if I paid like 50 bucks on
massaging there was that dude I wouldn't
Araki yeah his head looks like it's
wearing like a headpiece it looks like a
helmet definitely did wait what were you
just saying before that Boyd oh yeah
he's getting blowjobs his friends not
getting blowjobs at this parlor there's
a hole and you go get a blowjob from
like under the table yeah so wait you
you lay on the table and there's
basically a woman under there right
there's a glory they show you a hot
woman or show you hot woman and then you
think it's great they do a great job and
then that place got busted mm-hmm
because they found out it was like slave
labor right all these kids from where
was it like yeah Vietnam Vietnam or
Cambodia Tamizh and it was all boys that
we're doing it yes yeah he got a
multiple multiple boys slave blowjob
yeah and these kids are like America
everything will be different mini on the
table sucking anonymous dick oh not
Vietnamese girls but Vietnamese boys
that's so crazy
have you ever think about that like some
people's like you know that that fantasy
for a lot of people of like getting to
America and they're like oh yeah that's
the awesome place and for that being
like how many people something like that
is there reality for most people like
when it becomes your worst thing ever
well I mean that is the worst you know
here I mean there's a lot of you know
people from Mexico and stuff who have
like pretty rough jobs oh this is such a
bummer is like I would take care I
always talk to like cab drivers you know
and there most of them are like
I was uh I had a PhD in chemistry I know
that's yeah you take a hit because so
that either the next generation can be
okay yeah yeah I was an engineer that's
my oh my god I'm an engineer and you're
like oh really no like yeah I used to do
like stuff with our space program and
fucking whatever and you're like but
it's their space right real shit
yeah they got stuck in a tree man I'm
glad that we have a chance to do this
it's just a quick dental update I am
completely fixed now I have all my
cavities have been filled look at
kumail's eyes and I I am I'm good to go
I am gonna get mouth those dishes like
that they have they fit you have just
got him you did for whitening not for
whitening this is for like my job okay
do you snore yeah this is gonna help
that too yeah I just know like a son of
a bitch like yeah you know Emily's the
first like I've had every weight so heat
his jaw
can we give another can I I can pop my
jaw you want to see it oh yeah fuck if
you could see it I don't know if you can
see it properly but it's like oh we I
was like 14 and I yarn once and my jaw
got stuck open slightly more than you
can imagine how far you can open your
mouth and they're slightly more than
that
oh and it was just like totally stopped
like super open and I was just like
screaming I was like hitting my chin to
like get it in place and I smacking got
in place but since then since that day I
can pop my dress holy shit are you
scared that's never gonna go over that
and do it again was so bad like I
immediately I could five seconds there
was oh my god there was that video you
seen that video they just had no no that
girl the girl I think that happened -
she went to yawn and they they had her
featured it was on it's like a British
girl I think on a show like a medical
show
she showed up and they they actually put
like
what are they like tongue depressors
together something like that and they
stacked them and they had her put it in
her mouth just beyond what it already
was and that I think that made like the
muscle eventually like relax or
something it was great
that fucking happened to you yeah yeah I
was stuck but you you Jacqueline I was
like I like to start in three seconds I
was crying like tears down my face oh my
it's like the worst you're 14 years old
yeah I think since then I can pop my job
so you have a lot of dental did you have
a lot of dental problems we we've had a
lot of dental things happening lately my
wife and I really yeah that dentists
funny because I fucking it's been a
hadn't been to the dentist in like 15
years 15 years yeah I remember my last
night the dentist was I got a Star Wars
toothbrush wow I was like I remember
being excited about it wait a minute do
you have like so I went yeah I went like
six months ago I was like I gotta go I
gotta go
and I went that and she looked and she
was like it was like I knew it was gonna
be bad this is a bit I do about this
whole dental thing yeah but I knew it
was gonna be bad she was like you have
any symptoms and I said if I'd ice cream
on the right side of my mouth my spine
hurts which actually if I did it would
be like a shock like I could feel it in
my toes that's how bad I was so I went
and she was like she was there and she
was like okay this is gonna be a long
thing we have to do surgery there's one
tooth we have to get out like right now
she's like we have to do it right now
right now and I was like no I freaked
out I ran home really I got home and
Emily was like laughing and I was like
don't laugh this years and I told her
never he was like you have to go back
yeah all the doctors that day and I was
like I'm sorry gonna come back and I
went back and she like got one out it
took like two hours she had to cut the
tooth into five pieces what and she's
fucking showing him to me I'm like don't
show me show me when it's the last thing
that I need then show me like oh look at
this piece see she shows me the first
time like it's fine
if different pieces she had to like cut
it with like hmm yeah those things I
could feel like just like shit hitting
my face he smell too and the whole time
like 17 again is playing you know that
movie with Zac Efron right so he's like
making threes well I'm a grown man
fucking so there was like six months of
surgeries like really did you get an
implant or did you get a bridge or no
root canals I did one root canal and
there's still work that needs how many
cavities it was like every single tooth
that can have a cavity had a cavity
really just the front ones didn't every
other single one did I had all four my
wisdom teeth pulled
yeah this three pole the one is gonna be
another one there's gonna be five pieces
so we're waiting wait what's the five
piece thing it what happens is so you
have your tooth you know like that this
had running roots so that means this
toots roots go under the other tooth
but this dudes is healthy healthier so
it's like roots going under so she had
to like cut it to get like all the brian
drop it again you drop it I just crazy
that is like the best dental update
we've ever had that beats the
combination don't you think yeah I'm
just I'm to the point now I'm just
thinking about whitening that's all I
want to do yeah now I want to do
whitening but I got I gotta get a crown
in one two if you had just serious
dental shit man you're gonna have to be
a regular on the show we needed updates
I was going every single week
are you like five months whoa every
single week are you a flosser I am now
now I'm like super super right i floss
every day I yeah I used this shit got me
into flossing big-time big-time yeah I
mean I really dig it I love the way it
feels
I can't believe sometimes like sometimes
as I'm flossing out really pause and
I'll be like the fact that I didn't do
this for like a hundred years for every
year before is really just I mean I
remember I was I came home and I didn't
want to do it and I read cuz I go to
this burger place they have this burger
place
yeah they're you know
no like a burger place yeah
Buffalo and they have a thing about why
Buffalo's healthy and it says Buffalo
doesn't get it's the only mammal that
doesn't get cancer
now you think you've probably eaten so
much cancer like some of these fucking
have you know the effect cancer the
ground grinded up you've eaten cancer
yeah it's the only that doesn't get
cancer and it said Native Americans
that's the only meat they ate and they
would have lived to be over a hundred if
they have adequate dental care so most
of these guys were dying from like
dental infections jeez they can like get
in your bloodstream yeah I know I was
like I gotta go my Dennis was telling me
that that the they did a study in Africa
of like these really remote African
tribes and you read and you think you
forget about sometimes like there's no
there's no dental or medical care
whatsoever oh yeah right and so he's
like so you'd think like these would be
people with like just like like
everybody has three teeth and they're
like you know just holes he's like all
have all their teeth perfectly white
wonderfully healthy and like they've
never brushed they never like they've
you know and it's like why they only eat
protein and protein is basically like if
you're eating protein our diets are just
a mix of so many other things but the
big thing that hurts our teeth a lot are
carbohydrates yeah car was turning the
sugar so he's like these people have
basically a zero carb diet and carbs are
something that could really damage your
teeth this is turning into one of the
real impressive dental segments geez I
yeah I it was a nightmare and I hated
going and I actually the first time when
I went back she put me down and she
started doing the thing and I started
freaking out and she gave me a cold
compress to calm me down like that's how
she's like you need to calm down she
gave me a cold comp which is not her job
yeah and um she's our minion and I'm so
glad cuz they were talking to each other
and I I'm so glad I couldn't understand
what they were saying yeah yeah ask me
the hook or whatever you know I don't
want to hear that shit they didn't offer
you nitrous they didn't offer me no not
at all they they I mean they gave me and
I can't
asking for more novocaine however that
is over and over and I was like
novocaine novocaine novocaine that was
one of my favorite things I actually was
a good memory was when I got my wisdom
teeth well now they fucked me up so so
perfectly yeah because they what you do
is you take this is how you this is how
they did it back then at least when I
was a senior in high school or something
yeah taking take a valium tonight to
give you the valium take that when you
before you go to bed earlier when you
wake up the appointments in the morning
when you wake up in the morning take a
hot girl yeah right
they take two you take a morning valium
so then as soon as you wake up you take
a valium you get there they put you they
put the mask on yeah literally I go I
just go when are we gonna but the next
thing I say is when are we gonna start
and they go you're done yes I was like
no way and then they give you just pain
pills like bottle of pain pills and it
was just like that's how I just milked
that shit for days you know that's
amazing it was incredible it was really
I hadn't gotten my wisdom teeth out I
mean that's crazy we have to we have to
get you out of here I'm sorry I've kept
you so long I can't believe I didn't
even mention throughout the whole time
that Kumail also has definitely one of
the best shows if not the best show in
Los Angeles for stand-up meltdown at
meltdown comics on it is anime if you'd
loved seeing live stand-up and amazing
stand-ups I've been fortunate I've done
the show before but you can see just
like just great comics and then just a
mate like super star comics pop yeah
like Daniel Tosh can we do Martin like
we've had it was a container to hold on
because eras come by right yeah yeah I
mean we've been really lucky yeah it's
always it's always great what have you
back what books in July but we'll have
you back in August awesome thank you
mommies it was a lot of fun thank you
I mean creating roomies you're welcome
mommy you have to say bye mommy bye
mommy bye mommy
hi mommy hi mommy